well as you've been saying last night
Boris Johnson and Jeremy Corbyn took
part in that final head-to-head debate
Assante YouGov poll calling the contest
well pretty much a draw 52% to 48% for
Boris Johnson there's a margin of error
built in that of course Jeremy Corbyn is
trailing in the polls needed a
breakthrough moment didn't get one it
was pretty much a safety-first
sort of contest really well down a
magnet we were following the Labour
campaign and she's in burying South
Wales this morning I mean that there
really needed to be a game-changer for
Jeremy call when he didn't have won last
night does that put the pressure on for
the next five days I think so he is now
touring marginal seats here in Wales
really trying to make sure that they
swing his way he doesn't need that much
for this to be a hung parliament but if
the polls are anything to go by at the
moment it looks like the Tories are on
for a majority and it was interesting in
that debate last night it could have
been the moment where he really went on
the attack against Boris Johnson or
where he came out with a particular card
up his sleeve but he clearly didn't have
one and it was very much a kind of
rehearsed party lines that both leaders
came out with I think if you've been
following this election campaign from
the start you won't have heard anything
in that debate that you'd heard before
and Jeremy Corbyn given the fact that
Boris Johnson's campaign has been aid
talking about getting brexit done and be
going on the attack against Jeremy
Corbyn mr. Corbyn didn't really go on
the attack back I mean he talked to him
about his record on Islamophobia it says
I hope Prime Minister you recognize the
hurt that you have caused to people but
he really didn't go for the jugular
I suppose in line with what he we've
heard often over the course of this
campaign which is when they go low we go
high and I just wonder whether it would
have made a difference if he decided to
go more on the attack you know that you
gov pol with those numbers that that are
so cursed in this country really over
the last few years since the referendum
48
fifty-two essentially people seem to
think that in that debate Boris Johnson
came across as more prime ministerial
but Jeremy Corbyn was more to be trusted
if you look back at 2017 and you compare
the sort of rise in Labour's ratings and
in mr corbyn's popularity after the
manifesto was published with now you're
seeing a bit of a shift up but it's
certainly not to the extent that it was
two years ago there was a pollster on
this program a couple of weeks ago who
said I think it's impossible to
re-inflate that balloon and I think
those words were very fitting it's it's
odd but handy having our Moscow
correspondent in Barry this morning
because obviously we've got this this
whole line that it's been around in the
week a little bit but now these this
move from reddit to ban 61 accounts of
it says a link to this NHS report that
that labor were were using the other
week to claim that the NHS was up for
grabs
if the Conservative government got in
what are we to make of all of this and
at least the the possibility that there
has been an attempted Russian
interference in this election yes this
is this particular group called
secondary infection that Facebook
identified on it's a cat account a
couple of months ago and earlier in the
week we heard that there were
suggestions that the documents released
on reddit may also have been amplified
if not obtained but at least amplified
by a campaign that bore all the
hallmarks of this secondary infection
group which was associated with Russia I
think the implication is that clearly
these Russian trolling operations are
trying to interfere we know that as a
almost as a policy they look to exploit
divisions and cracks within democratic
processes in the West
clearly the implication here is that it
is more beneficial for Russia to see
likes of Jeremy Corbyn perhaps in power
he is not as it may continue the
uncertainty I suppose over brexit if he
calls for a second referendum you know
that that is all taking it five steps
ahead but I think what is important is
is the fact that these groups are
associated with Russia they're clearly
trying to needle any way that they can
in the functioning of this election for
whatever purpose that you may wish to
then attribute further up the chain and
it is important to identify closely how
and what is responsible jeremy corbyn's
position on this so far has been really
to say well look at Boris Johnson he
needs to release the Russia report which
is absolutely true and valid but I think
labour also needs to give some answers
as to where exactly they sourced this
document from perhaps it was emailed to
them in exactly the same way as it was
to various journalists once it was
published on the reddit site but labour
needs to be more outspoken about the
possibility of Russian interference in
this campaign okay Diana for now thank
you